animal diseases can be spread easily
from farm to farm and across the
countryside when livestock and poultry
are transported dirty trucks and
trailers might carry pathogens down the
road onto other farms or ranches and
into facilities for biosecurity
follow these guidelines if you will be
picking up livestock or poultry the farm
or ranch probably has designated one
secure entry point for empty trucks
coming in the farmer or Rancher may give
you a phone number or may post a sign
that provides the phone number to call
or gain admittance to the premises they
should then admit only vehicles they
trust who won't contaminate the
operation or that they can examine
before entering your contact may inspect
the truck and trailer before you went to
the premises if there's mud or manure
you may be asked to leave to clean the
equipment thoroughly or be directed to
cleaning facilities outside the premises
you may be asked to sign a log of when
you enter and leave provide contact
information and confirm what condition
your equipment is in when you arrive and
depart you should be shown what route to
take on the operation and where to loan
before animals are loaded for transport
examine the required paperwork a
certificate of veterinary inspection
which is commonly called a CVI or health
certificate may be required or may be
optional if the animals are going
directly to slaughter this certificate
is required if livestock are transported
across state lines the rules vary among
states so contact your state animal
health official state veterinarian or
local vet to clarify requirements a
certificate of brand inspection may be
required to confirm that cattle have
brands on them for proof of ownership a
bill of lading describes what's on the
truck typically the number of animals in
each class a bill of sale confirms a
change of ownership like a receipt make
sure you have clean Footwear and
coveralls when loading and any time
around animals before animals are loaded
make sure clean outs are closed on
trailers this will keep manure from
being real
during the trip confirm that clean and
not reused betting is on your truck with
the farmer or Rancher examine animals as
they're being loaded don't load sick or
injured animals instead work with the
producer to sort them out for
examination and possible treatment when
done loading double-check the paperwork
to confirm the number of each class of
animal loaded and make sure all gates
are closed log when your truck leaves
the premises and any other information
that should be recorded if you're
delivering animals to a farm or ranch
again call to gain admittance to the
premises follow the route given and sign
in if requested before animals are
unloaded from transport examine the
required paperwork with the producer
these may include a certificate of
veterinary inspection certificate of
brand inspection bill of lading bill of
sale before or while animals are
unloaded work with the producer to
verify and document numbers and classes
of animals for example the number of
cows guilts or use and possibly each
animals identification such as your tag
or ear notch if an animal looks sick
work with the producer to separate it
from the others as soon as possible the
new animals could infect on-premises
animals with a contagious disease if
possible after unloading move your
transportation equipment to a cleaning
area where it can be hosed down to
remove manure before it goes back on the
road or to another farm or ranch if not
possible immediately complete a thorough
clean out as soon as possible so whether
you're delivering new animals to an
operation or transporting off the
premises these procedures will help you
keep the animals healthy
you